moi je pense que ce qui est en train de
changer c'est que les consciences
s'éveillent les esprits ces va et voyez
quand moi j'ai lancé mon alerte ya 15
ans ces thématiques de dire la vérité de
de parler d'eux c'était complètement
controversé maintenant et puis là on
traverse cette époque que kovy d'où on
voit qu'il ya des voix qui se lève et
qui sont immédiatement
alors si c'est pas censuré mais en tout
cas c'est assez c'est assez violent pour
ceux qui essayent d'avoir des propos
différents et qu'en fait ce qui est en
train de changer c'est que les citoyens
vont chercher l'information
ils se contentent plus de récupérer ce
qu'on leur dit comme ça et que je pense
que c'est là où cet éveil des
consciences était quand même très
redouté et que c'est en train d'arriver
donc ça va changer forcément la donne ça
va changer le paradigme et ça va aussi
changer la façon dont de journalisme va
être va être fait à l'avenir parce que
sinon ce n'est pas de l'information mais
c'est de la propagande
[Musique]